entre les états unis et la chine bien
sûr il ya les arsenal nucléaire mais moi
je ne pense pas qu'on puisse écarter
aujourd'hui
l'hypothèse d'un affrontement peut être
sans doute bref sans doute localisée
mais ce serait bien d'optimiste de dire
qu' il se passera rien autour de taiwan
dans les dix années qui viennent on
riait ou dans les mers de chine
donc nous excluent pas complètement qu'à
un moment donné un avion tire sur un
autre qu'un bateau soit écoulé quelque
chose alors les chinois que savent les
américains de sabre s'il y avait en
chine
des gens qui se disent que compte tenu
de l'état de l'occident les convulsions
internes sociales politiques
idéologiques la certain déclin
économique 19 à toute une série
d'éléments négatifs plus une amérique
copé en 2 politiquement et des élections
en permanence en occident siens un parti
en chine qui se dit c'est le moment d'en
profiter pour repousser les pions du
côté de taiwan là ce serait vraiment
dangereux vraiment dangereux parce que
pour les états unis accepté là que pékin
recontrôle par la force ou par
l'intimidation taïwan ça voudrait dire
que la garantie américaine ne voudrait
plus rien nulle part nulle part dans le
monde et donc les ya un facteur de
désagrégation potentiel gigantesque
très dangereux
[Musique]